[Musique]
nos téléphones sont devenus des applications essentielles
pour suivre nos horaires, notre forme physique,
nos vies amoureuses, mais si une application pouvait
vous dire combien de temps j'ai eu 63 ans 57
ans avant votre mort, voudriez-vous
savoir que cette application est fausse, évidemment ma
petite amie  a dit la même chose je savais
que l'application avait dit qu'elle allait mourir quoi
qu'il nous arrive je pense que c'est à cause
de ce
bonsoir ton téléphone et toi
suivant nouveau numéro ton service
[Musique]
tout ce que je peux t'aider avec Non
[  Applaudissements]
l'application de compte à rebours c'est vraiment juste un
nombre aléatoire avec une horloge ce n'est pas si
effrayant
mais il semble que cela a fonctionné sur les
clowns de YouTube cela doit être tout le monde qui a
téléchargé l'application elle l'a téléchargée tout ce que
nous devons faire est de battre l'horloge d'une
seconde  tu as déjà fait quelque chose comme ça
avant non mais j'ai beaucoup lu à ce sujet
c'est un destin bien pire que la mort
te poursuivra viens avec moi
ça ne te submergera pas jusqu'à ce que tu
sois complètement détruit tu appelles mon
nom
[  Musique]
vous